so jetzt
die anderen oder danach dominierte 2000
tieren den salat
sie war wissenschaftliche mitarbeiterin
im hirn
mit
eine auslands auch im fall des bildes
sind amerikanischen mellon university
und 2001 bis 2004 war sie aber den
michael
seit 2004 ist sie professorin für
angewandte informatik insbesondere
community zu sehen
[Musik]
ihre schwerpunkte gegen australien ins
wattenmeer interpretieren dass das
menschen ständiges maschinelles lernen
und kommentieren
jetzt wird's spannend und informativ
workshops für kinder und jugendliche an
der zeit diesen kranen das hat uns der
wirtschaftsinformatik
sie hält dort hin zum thema
die grundschule ist aktiv im bereich
keine illusionen wir gestalten gerade
wenn es am ende des kurses einer
bildungs und bei der großen gemeinde zum
thema kunst außerdem waren das
entspricht ganz bisschen mitsprechen
können
[Musik]
dazu kommen ja die ausführliche
anleitungen und tolle erinnerungen haben
die vorträge bis ihr wahnsinnig spannend
ich habe übrigens zwei vorträge
mitgebracht was gesagt eine anzahl
vorgesehen wenn ich nicht so ganz in
ruhe mein schwerpunkt sechs mittel nicht
brüssel abhängig machen von dem was
vorher gebunden ist jetzt ist mein ich
habe auch keine körper keine folien
mitgebracht folien mit
zur abwechslung und sein
bin ich so ein bisschen missionarische
unterwegs wir haben ja und zwar als der
mann dies noch die digitalisierung durch
schulen digitales lernen und die
künstliche intelligenz und bei beiden
sehe ich viel aktionismus und ich glaube
wir müssen ein bisschen mehr hintergrund
haben mit nachdenken wie das heute
wollen forderungen basierendes und ich
war dir zusammen anfangen mich vor allem
darauf konzentrieren und bricht dann den
zweiten teil nicht mehr bei kunden
sozusagen denn introduction region zu
machen also ein bisschen der einführung
was ist künstliche intelligenz
ausrichter künstlichen intelligenz haben
änderungen
okay das las das top thema ist uns klar
dann kommen so aus wie die autos müssten
es sein denken können
wir hatten die sensation mit dem gong
oder das ist als nächstes mit dem
bäuerlichen größeren noch optimum
geknackt wurde
wir hatten den blick frei auf die
blondine
man hat ihm die blonde zwei das gleiche
und erfindung des silicon valley aus der
jüngsten zeit nicht so ganz war an den
börsen das kopfunter leben die großen
internationalen die machen alle
inzwischen kg die han startups und
andere unternehmen aufgekauft noch und
nöcher
vielleicht verlieren wir uns bei den
roboter der haben heute schon von ex
machina kloster fall ist aber dann
kommen eben auch dinge die tödliche
unfall eines tesla längster sorgt immer
mal wieder für mystische polizei einige
bestellungen dann die angst des
jobverlustes wobei es da mal ganz lustig
finde wenn man dachte ja immer dass die
nicht akademischen mittel für die ganz
geworden sind aber einer der mehr nutze
der am wenigsten einsetzbar ist wäre es
aus meisters des facility manager und
einer der worüber man redet
steuerberatung rechtsprechung
personalselektion eine einstellung der
schweiz
relativ einfach algorithmen zu genügen
hausmeisters deutlich komplexere dinge
tun kann also es ist auch thema in
politik wirtschaft und gesellschaft auch
in eine schule und verbinden damit viele
hoffnungen daten zu wissen ja man wird
immer wieder brachten sind das
neuenbürger und ich auch gerne
differenzierte mal drüber reden wollen
das so ist wir kriegen strategien für
immer bessere und personalisierte
lösungen internet ins leben hinter in
das libretto umfang in der bildung ist
die debatte heute
wir haben die hoffnung von karrieren
rasten uns menschen und übernahme von
gewährleistungen stimmt ihnen arbeiten
aber es gibt auch viele ängste haben wir
vorher auch schon mal einen vortrag
gehört entscheiden die kühlsysteme für
uns übernehmen die die macht darf neckar
ihr auto moment scheidung diese debatte
alle gewährt haben das autonome wiens
soll das auto überfahren es in zwei in
der entscheidung betreffe die frage ist
folgt wie unsere kinder untersucht und
keine jungs in einen topf geben
die ganzen diskussionen
dann kann ich auch sehr geehrte kann ja
auch schon anderes in der region ist
muss und diese ganzen cent nach trinken
kultur ich meine hammer in den kunden
kannten und vorbei mensch eine
manipulierbare kunde keine zu werben für
produkte parteien meinungsmache und so
weiter als hoffnungen und ängste
die wahrheit wird irgendwo wundermittel
liegen und ich werde jetzt ein bisschen
grundlage allgemein was die skalierung
auf mehr
einige hören ein bisschen über maschen
des langen reden vielleicht wenn ich
dann noch dazu kommen auch über
partnerschaft statt automobili und
jemanden es tatsächlich mit methoden wie
versuchen kann ja alles okay gibt schon
weg ist sogar ein ganz festes beratung
typischen intelligence das erste mal als
begriff auftauchte nämlich anlässen
konferenz die ein informatiker john
mcgough sie mit anderen die sie unten
sehen durchführen wollte und sie hatten
keinen namen dafür was die
wissenschaftler verband waren keine
wissenschaftlerinnen dabei war die idee
die annahme dass jeder aspekt von
intelligenz so präzise geschrieben
werden kann dass ihn ein computer
simulieren kann
hörer zeilen hat 57 dann wahnsinnig
viele gewartet
auch das mache ich nicht so gerne
klicken es ist mir vielleicht noch mal
an oder mit
[Musik]
kann ich nicht mehr geplant ist
man kann nicht verliert
solange den nächsten die kohle kriege
ich das
gut da probiert so ja also viele
operationen der erwartung zum beispiel
157 gesagt in den nächsten jahren und
ein computer schachweltmeister immerhin
trat dann 97 also mit etwas verspätung
aber immerhin und es war damals eine
sensation und ich möchte sagen es war
tatsächlich nur in rheine
suchen in datenbanken und reines
regelten das problem des aufsteigers
sogenannten heuristischen suche hinter
kanada wurden tolle wollen das
entwickelt die dazu führte dass karthago
greif zwischendurch meinte das sei ein
mensch die hintergrund und nicht wie
computer es gab dann allerdings ziemlich
schnell fehlschläge wahrscheinlich
kennen viele von ihnen diesen ersten
peinlichen bis zum thema maschinelle
übersetzung colorado versucht wurde vom
englischen ins russische unsere zu
übersetzen und dann kam bei der geist
ist willig aber das fleisch schwach was
zugegeben jetzt ja nicht so ganz trivial
ist eben raus der rocker ist gut aber
das fleisch fest verbaut
und das ist hat sagen das und viele
andere dinge haben vom ersten ersten 13
war
wir wollen nicht kurz
deutlicher als der jetzt die erste phase
da klima geprägt davon dass man
wahnsinnig schnell erfolge hatte mit
algorithmen simulationen für viele
bereiche der allgemeinen intelligenz in
ihren spielen lernen problem lösen
planen sprachverstehen die ware immer
einen ganz kleinen treu domains das
heißt was die erste was am anfang an
nicht geklappt hat war sie übertragen
vom kleinen bruder von ihren problemen
in die echte welt in großen datenmengen
und danach stehen in england würde den
forschungsgeldern
alle gestrichen es war die erste grosse
kein blinder dann kamen zwei
wissensbasiertes systemen erwarten idee
ja wir müssen wir bekommen jetzt
supertolle in veränderungen schaffen
denn es müssen so schwierige sache
gelöst volle ironman gewissen was sie
können und was nicht
jetzt ist er ja nur noch das wissen der
menschen extra touren ja mit anderes
problem gelöst gesagt sehe ich ihn los
mäßiges technokratische denken was zum 2
1 geführt hat weil ja nicht man erkennen
musste dass es hier das match
entschieden botnet gibt das menschliche
extra trainer gerade jemand ist wer so
viel wissen über die erfahrung ins leben
zwischen was erleben nicht mal sagen
kann was er oder sie alles gute zum
beispiel um einen guten unterricht zu
machen
so spricht experte systeme sind auch von
ovationen
was man dann ein bisschen an die wand
gefahren das war der zweite winter ich
selber auch in dem karree winter ohne
ende groß geworden und hätte sich vor
drei jahren gefragt ob jemals wieder das
wort künstliche intelligenz in genommen
wird und ob sie ihren ersten der nicht
verstehen denn die systeme kognitive
systeme oder wissensbasierte systeme
leisten sondern tatsächlich am ende 2 31
stunden und gesagt nein
also es für sich ein großes gerade für
mich wissenschaftspolitische erlebnis zu
sehen ist unheimlich spiel genau und ich
denke aber wir müssen wirklich
vorsichtig sein winter ist kamin auf
jeden fall folgt auch wieder ein winter
und ich probiere über die nächsten folie
werning gegen die gleiche platz zu
machen warum ist ein anlass ihres dinge
vielleicht gar keine überziehungen aber
schneller in die man fahren meistens
blieb es worum geht es denn im bereich
kann erforscht wie man computer dazu
bringen
die menschen im moment noch besser
können oder die karriere fast sie mit
informatikprobleme die bislang nicht
gelöst und zwei gängigen definition ich
habe extra genommen bei denen ich
vermeiden das wort intelligente zu
verwenden weil er dann natürlich sofort
in der diskussion kommen über die
definition des intelligenz begriffs
darüber kann man sehr gerne diskutieren
aber das wollte ich im moment ja außen
vor lassen man muss sich erstmals klar
machen dass karin keine erfindung der
neuzeit ist das keine möglichen tyler
informatik ist und natürlich auch viele
interdisziplinäre bezügen hat in der
psychologie in der philosophie des
geistes da hat man schon einiges gehört
beispielsweise früher
das marinegeschäft bordcomputers canto
nehmen viele erkennen des philosophisch
spannende fragen und auch mit der
sprachwissenschaft innerhalb
deutschlands ist die lamellen kapiert da
findet dieses jahr standen 20 468
konferenz statt
und was mich besonders freut ist kärnten
arbeitskreis gegründet vom fachbereich
didaktik der informatik gemeinsam jemand
eine lebensschule das sind sehr viele
interessierte informanten die daktiker
aber leider bislang nicht sehr viel gold
der osten verlagern seite ex machina als
freude auch schon gefallen damit ich
sehen wie die verführerische roboters ex
machina wir haben auch schon los das
starke team fordert die marktkunden des
seriösen wissenschaftler innerhalb der
machen schwachen heiß wir probieren
informatik lösungen für komplexe
bereiche zu entwickeln bei denen noch
drei menschen üblicherweise zu
schreibers intelligenz erforderlich ist
natürlich ist gerade ich es mit meinem
hintergrund suchen und die und
informatik ist es auch legitim zu sagen
ich möchte mich nur informatik lösungen
bei uns und ich möchte die
computermodellierung nutzen und
natürlich intelligenz besser zu
verstehen indem ich versuche es zwei
weisen abzubauen
das ist kann man euro entstanden
aufpassen die annahme wäre dann computer
und roboter können auf die gleiche art
sein gehalt entgangen seien die menschen
gehört in und robotern fehlen die
internationalität das denke ich ist eine
wirklich spannende debatte diese annahme
ursprünglich wurde mal von zwei der
gründungsväter der unter dem schlagwort
flüssiges in dem prozess ein geben wird
wo sie eben sagten von physikalischen wo
es im internet ist notwendig und in
reichen für zeugen identen verein ist
hinreichend sind sozusagen den
mechanistisch die freie der mensch nicht
herauszuholen reinigungsmaschinen mal
was sind wird den andern ist als eine
freundin von neuronen im
rechnungsprozess wenn auch keinen
digitaler auf der anderen seite ist
hinreichend würde uns dann sagten er gut
da kann ich auch damit schreiben die
dazu führen dass andere intelligenzen
das ist eine spannende debatte
die muss man führen dass folge man immer
darüber nachdenken aber wie gesagt die
meist schwachen karrieren die meisten
leiden interpretieren zum vorstand kein
hinein
die meisten wissenschaftler davon darf
nicht aus dass bei dem nichts den sabina
tor haben wir das super jungen
intelligence hat die entscheide das
label zugrunde richten und dann könnte
uns übergreifend schaffen sehen die
meisten nicht die größten braten kann
ein
die beiden eigenen bilden haben das
wurde bei der internationalität und
bewusste entscheidungen treffen die es
insofern auch beantworten also das ist
natürlich auch philosophisch nie so ganz
klar das erste mal bewusst sein was
genau ist sind wir menschen neigen sehr
schnell wieder dinge die sich bewegen
intentional its beziehung zu schreien
und biss sie ja auch bei denen nicht was
die aktuelle mentale zustand werden
viele waschsalons berichten englischen
garten und aber was ihre ziele sind sehe
ich nicht es ist eine zuschreibung nicht
einen sensationellen
wir müssen und wir menschen sind
wahnsinnig versucht alles was sich
bewegt dasselbe zuzuschreiben
deswegen passiert dann auszugehen wenn
roboter ligatreffer der toll aussieht
und dann ein gutes crypt ist beruhigend
wenn man damit nach wirklichkeit machen
will macht schon mal das mit den kameras
nicht weiteres uns weiter
also so toll funktioniert es nicht auch
in skripten youtube videos gibt dann
haben wir im moment ich mag es anders
verhält als er zum beispiel nicht bei
etwas nachfrage gesenkt und infor
wiederholen ist wirklich dran
kombination angepasst werden
ein konzert und vielleicht doch zum
thema intelligent ist wobei ich das in
oberen direct urintest kann man meine
auch schon und bestiegen
ich möchte nur auf den ganzen unteren
teil kurz eingehen
intelligentes passieren auf
internationalität
haben momentan gehört es gibt mir ein
wunderbares studien und zweite symbol
oben auf
fünfziger jahren die mit einfachsten
mitteln einen trick sind mit beweg
symbolen immer zu tag mehr da ist nichts
darüber
und wir haben menschen beschreiben
lassen passt in diesen trick 15
ja und dann bekam ihren aus angst los
eine mischung
auch hier ließ die geometrische objekte
internationale handlungen vom achten
das freilegen des kleinen leute vor dem
großen becken eher kleinen kreis der
mächtigen die nation geben und so weiter
passiert sofort körper gar nicht
vermeiden
gefährliches muster erkennen
sie sitzen bisschen alte mbit/s ich habe
nichts besseres gefunden der mann sich
sagt sag mir was schon cds
dann kommt eben aus kompost schlamperei
der mustererkennung ist eben nicht
verstehen und einer der großen cognitive
science vorschlag der ein wunderbares
dokumenten absatz gestiegenen
kohlepreise
finden sie orden eingangs und der fakt
dass eben das sozusagen ist jetzt für
menschen die sich in der forschung sind
dass die maschinen erst mal wahnsinnig
uns in vielen dingen zum beispiel wir
kennen in jeder perspektive in
stoppschild und mir ab aber dann machen
sie einen fehler und das ist ein fehler
den wir niemanden
wir wollten vielleicht ein stoppschild
im nehmen mit einem anderen ruhigen
schrittes verwechseln
aber wir würden das stoppschild nicht
mit einem alligator wächst ja und das
kennen sie vielleicht in diesem kontext
vielleicht man so ein genannt die
learnings system das in völlig andere
dinge zu behaupten zu sehen und dann ist
immer wieder zurück im an kennen welche
in einer großen enttäuschung
also sprich wie möglich wissen kg
funktionieren
dahinter steckt wenn ihr dazu einerseits
würden fällig schätzte erwartungen so
ein auto das jetzt von der schild und
das erkennt fußgänger würde doch gar
nicht erkennen ob da eine junge frau
oder eine alte frau stellt warum sollte
man das auto denn darauf trainieren
trainieren es noch darauf dass das
tragen von fußgängern geschäft um zu
wissen ob es ausreichen muss ja und wir
denken habe nur weil es passt kann kann
das jetzt auch in scheinbar bestens
jandl und der frau dann manchmal tut es
nicht natürlich
also das ist ja nur eine feier der
bilderkennung und freudenstadt und da
gibt es viele teilgebiete es gibt jene
bücher die über unsere zeit häufig
wissenschaftler aus anderen disziplinen
im radio
aus den interviews geben häufig sind es
sich oft ähnlich wie man so nahe
günstiger zum teil sind es auch
wirtschaftswissenschaftler die dann ins
kreishaus sind nicht möchte echten
dimensional trinken wenn natürlich muss
man das internet viele mehr angehen und
informatik ab inbegriffen 78 wenn ich
dann aber hören was sich im rat jemanden
dass jemand sagt k die kann man nicht
trainieren
dann denke ich in eine kreativ ort ist
auch andere länder zum beispiel die gibt
es natürlich kann man es natürlich nicht
abschieben kann ich definieren wie das
oder wissenschaft immer deshalb ein
[Musik]
kleiner trend denn so dass gleichgesetzt
wurden das wirklich vorwarnen zb der
kommentar ist nur ganz klein zicker dax
und entsprechend ist ein ganz klarer in
falcos karten zeichnen sich dadurch aus
dass die institute ihren
verhaltensweisen genannt
namens- oder verluste bei produkten und
liebe gehen digitalisierung und kein
bisschen traurig dass setzen auch manche
leute reich digitalisierung heißt erst
ein analoger information in digitale
formate und dann kann ich sie ein
computerprogramm fahrrad weiters weisen
ist und datenintensive kg mit diesen
dingen profitiert von der
digitalisierung
umgekehrt kann keinen wie natürlich
digitalisierung unterstützen
rico schmitt sie als dokumente habe man
schließlich etwa oder ähnliches dann
wäre das natürlich toll wenn kein helfen
könnte in allen sprachen etwa die texte
entsprechenden digitalisieren
automatisch da hat mich witzigerweise
fange ich da gerade die forschungs
frühjahr kinder firma muss es darum
gehen rechnen
die leute sagen ja immer noch meistens
analog sind und dann in wunden
grafikformat und steuerberater kommen
dazu bekennen dass von der anrechnung
etwas kann ist big data 300 jedes mal
sehr genau
ein maschinelles lernen wenn so viele
daten gehen eine aktuellere glaubt ist
auch gerade im bereich end to end was
kann versprochen wird was macht man dann
nachdenken können da jetzt nicht vor als
idee ist und die lösung ist mehr lachen
ja es gibt riesige pumpe immer wenn wir
da nicht mal wissen also jeder der jetzt
im spross weiß dass es nicht allein
etwas repräsentatives haben will
erst eine lang machen muss über die
verteilung seiner grundgesamtheit mit
sich überhaupt nichts denken strategien
zu überdenken
passiert in diesen anwendungen ist
erschienen
die nicht vorher mal eine vorlesung war
angesagt
auch im privaten leben vorgefertigtes
900 des netzes kann man alles zusammen
große gefahren das kommt ja ganz um den
marktwert unter bin ich schneller kommen
als wir wenden weil dann nämlich einfach
die enttäuschung vorprogrammiert ist
machine is planen sind zweiteiligen
biete die erst mal aus ganz
unterschiedlichen traditionen kamen und
die miteinander verschmolzen sind die
muster signalverarbeitung es sehe aus
der technik und ist entschieden werden
dieser begriff kam originär ausparken
[Musik]
das 1 da ist ein kleiner 3 millionen um
die existenzsicherung spannend aber da
wir uns wieder
das habe ich heute sehr genossen den
sonntag von axel kromer da wären dann
nämlich wieder genau an diesem punkt das
soll jeder wie der jurist muss einführen
das heißt wir reduzieren das was
didaktisch wirkliche test endlich auf
eine schülerin oder ein schüler etwas
verstanden hat ja das lässt sich in
einem live bild waren bei dem käufer
fangen ja und winters islam fortschritt
rechnete stunde weiter man kann ihm
keiner das ist pure delta roboter ist
überwiegend nicht kann
die meisten roboter ist maschinen auf
aber natürlich gibt es eine kognitive
robotik in der kabine mensch roboter
interaktion machine learning habe ich
schon bisschen was zugesagt ist ein
bereich
echte teilmengen von karriere nicht das
kleine künstliche intelligenz angriff
herunter fallen die fordert schwarzer
folie viele themen die planen problem
lösen stilberaterin und land das
künstliche neuronale netze wieder an der
algarve und gegen die ordnung der zeit
in verschiedenen ansätzen wieder die
pioniere des maschine die angegeben mehr
auf junge noch schöner macht und wenn
das sagen leute die kamera dies sei aber
mit den worten einen entwickeln die das
menschliche lernen abbilden
genau das habe ich ihnen die ersten
bücher von diesem thema sind auch so
gekommen also ein
das von 1997 dafür ehrlich was alle
wunder und in ansätzen bekannt
aber das steht am anfang die
rechtfertigung und was maschine ist muss
man das stück bis heute ein dankeschön
an das großartige werbung von christof
bischof eigentlich zentrale basti
nachsehen hätten drei kommen schnell
verschiedene das heißt teile des
menschen die wirklich erwachsen wo man
mit wenig daten lassen kann wo man nur
ministerium und dominiert die sind ja
alle nicht mehr drin
dies ist dadurch eine andere perspektive
ist und natürlich in dem rücklicht
räumung von minen und fällungen können
die online vieles sehr lange bevor es
wirklich gut
da kommen die dinge auch nicht freuen ja
ich bin tatsächlich in die informatik
genannt in die forschung in psychologie
immer im studium immer mehr fasziniert
wie flexibel und vielfältig menschliches
lernen ist und das sollte ich besser
verstehen und das bin ich bis heute als
er verstehe nicht wie man wieder völlig
verwundert davor wie toll menschen
ich gehe jetzt aber die verschiedenen
landschaften und zeigte ihnen vielleicht
kleinen beispiel was mich dass man total
weil wir hier unten hin schauen auf
dieses bildes ist vom stammbaum einen
der wichtigsten komplette design des
vorstand von t
die märkte haben wir noch nie gesehen
diesen relativ für den gesamten komplex
her und die christliche rechte ein und
diese teilen die hilfstruppen wir sind
uns einig
heute funktioniert was zum beispiel nach
wahrscheinlichkeit ist das aber schon
und debattieren niemand widersprechen
und australien besteht ja ziemlich data
sich geladen hat könnte ich muss man
dazu mussten wir schon angst nicht viel
aus sehr vielen daten gelangt dass
fischer extraction einer formel 1 weiter
angeheizt
aber das ist sehr gut
lernen ist induktion und wir hatten
heute deutschland eine philosophische
verträge und das wirklich ermutigt dass
viele von ihnen nun ein bisschen den
hintergrund in logik haben das leck
schließen sie ja in demokratischer
manier haben alle menschen sind
sterblich
und das ist ein mensch mit dem release
von monster als aller welt das sind
stattlich und ich weiß dann kann nicht
daraus folgerungen aufgemalt nochmal des
reichs reduktion erlaubt und eine
manische syntaktische auf korrekte
logische schlüssel vom 7
ich darf das sagen wir verbunden sein
meine bereit
alle bmw gefahren peter des bmw-fahrers
spd
es gibt natürlich bmw fahrer sind keine
das heißt 80 begrenzt
das sehen sie der logische schluss ist
immer noch korrekt aber das setzt voraus
dass im kommission korrekt sind und das
steht außerhalb diese wahrheit ist nur
ausgestiegen und gegenüber tatsächlich
induktive kann haben wir vor uns haben
wir irgendwie die fahrer oder um die
preise zu drücken und dann haben wir den
eigenen wünschen der oper also hier
jetzt ich mache das mit dem song gratis
beispiel nicht mit bmw fahrer oder
machten us kongress stellen und ich weiß
das ist menschlich und wasser ist sei
noch ein paar menschen und dann generell
ist hier wirklich alle menschen
zugestanden dass ganzen entschieden
werden was hier aus solchen induktiven
schritten des rheins es gibt keine er
die 100-prozentige korrekt
neben eigenen genannt und lässt sich
feiern
und das muss man sich immer denn da
macht man kann sehr sorgfältig umgehen
und kann mit großen ruby und es seien
oder kundendaten aber es gibt keinen
korrekten spanischen was ist auch die
gibt es bei express nahmen
germanisierung stars überhaupt nur
möglich weil wir menschen reihenweise
haben ja ohne dass sich etwas verwischt
also so wichtiger da könnte ich nur
auswendig lernen heißt ja generalisieren
über drängenden themen szenen oder die
kindlichen sprache oder monat sprache
wie soll das funktionieren
wir sehen auch an dr
die stereotypen und vorurteilen und
warum frauen nicht einparken und wenden
nicht zuhören können sehen dass wir kann
man das alles hier und das hier einfach
so eine art liebe generalisierung des
maschinen sind was tun wir wenn wir auf
diese art über generalisierende nicht
uns die sozialpsychologie und andere
disziplinen dass wir mechanismen
entwickeln können uns solche stereotypen
und vorurteilen gegen swing und diese
aufzubrechen und daher zb spanien der
interdisziplinäre forschung dass man das
auch nicht erschienen
auf diese art werden cool ist vor allem
ausgeschieden ist mit dem 1
die mögliche generell es gibt aber auch
weil diese nicht ganz so und xl
hinweises ja wenn ich vorher noch nicht
mal nach bringen wir mögliche
verteidigung meiner daten ja dann noch
nicht nach einem riesenfehler und so war
es bei diesem tender bei facebook noch
ein anderes problem ist dass man sie
immer spieler die gerade immer so ganz
neu ist auch dass die vor plastik vier
monaten die macht einer sein
ja glauben sie das ist jemand der
personalabteilung sind neben dem gold
standard hat die war ein geht und welche
nicht wenn sie nach ordentlicher
spielerin machen wollen dann können sie
nicht sagen daten rein müssen raus da
machen sie erst mal fünf sechs jahre
wahnsinnig viel empirische forschung und
ähnliche fragen wenn sie erst mal
definieren müssen was ist denn gute
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter habe
das ist ja auch noch gewesen die nichts
bringen unternehmen
das hat ja auch putin struktur
zufriedenheit ins bein
und dann kann ich natürlich so nach
china nicht machen aber da steckt viel
geld aber nicht einfach nur daten die
nicht mehr weiterreden ich mache mir
noch kurz ein dass zu viel heute auch
schon das wort ich durch den vortrag
halten
und da hat einen sketch artist aus
meinem vortrag das gemacht und es
gefällt mir richtig gut
also ich arbeite daran dass ich keinen
so nutze und damit wurden entwickelt der
mensch maschine partnerschaft
ermöglichen und so würde ich das im
legaler und bildungsbereich sehen
ich glaube dass dieses reise auf
nacktschnecken und optimales lfb
juristische menschen die katastrophe ist
in jedem bereich in eur entwickelten
gesellschaft ich kann das mal sehen wenn
ich keine andere aufgabe
mehr sport machen warum nicht aber als
generell des menschen sind finde ich das
sehr sehr gefährlich ich glaube wir
müssen dahin gehen dass maschinen und
menschlich ergänzen dass maschinen
dielingen und überlebenden menschlich
leicht weniger zeit haben oder oder sich
so gut sind und dass wir den jungen
immer in den reisenden das hier aussagen
der mensch darf die maschine über
steigung die entscheidung der maschine
und auch die vorgänge klären und dann
komme ich jetzt nur noch zu einem
einzigen weit stimmt nämlich nämlich
dass ausbildungsbereichen carling als
künstlich gewerkschaft na also keine
listen ja gerade um die dinge april in
einer vorschau hier zwei gedacht nicht
von der unterricht werde die menschen im
moment noch besser können wenn ihr so
eine richtig tolle lehrerin oder lehrer
haben erst dann habe ich die person
ihrem leben stand erreicht die person
hat klar definierte kontext angemessene
angestammten aktiven prinzipien szene
erinnert und erkennt spezifischen
wissens
uns fehlen konzentrationen und
individueller ebene würde mich nach dem
großen lasten im unterricht wo ich
anders gemacht und sie reagiert im ziel
mit erklärungen und beispielen ja
natürlich will ich wenn ich sowas sagt
jetzt nichts sagen ich betone kreieren
die das selbst dann gelegentlich einen
individualisierten unterricht um gottes
willen ich glaube aber dass es zum teil
zum beispiel individualisierung kognitiv
machen könnte mit der gemeinde und lande
lernen schafft viele gezielten kindern
arbeiten können ja es ist ein
partnerschaftliches sagt ein beispiel
schriftliche fraktion dritte klasse
medien vermuten die meisten haben des
voller länge
lehrkräfte der einfache ist wenig zeit
haben oder einfach nur mit ansätzen mit
stürmischen winden und falsches ergebnis
liefert und was natürlich die aktuellen
umsätze auch im norden ist es korrekt
oder nicht
was ja aber eigentlich spannend ist wenn
es jetzt mal hier links unten gucken ist
das hier nur zwei gespalten der schüler
hier unten in wyhlen statt was uns
zeigen das sehr gut
diese konnte immerhin ein anhaltender
größeren abzieht die kleinen verfall
größere chance besteht ja so dass essen
und hese über nicht fehlen konzeption
dass er nicht einfach das ist falsch von
mir kennen eigentliches
verständnisproblem und darum geht es
auch unter bildung das in den verstehen
wollen wir haben nicht ausgeklammert
so jetzt nicht in geld und sagen
versuchs noch mal an
dieses beispiel hat
so konstruiert dass nicht das gleiche
muster aber mit anderem müsse man jetzt
und hier bestehen welche wenig wasser
das kind im sinne von den weg in den
laden mit hilfe von summen analogen weg
hoffentlich zeigen dass eltern kennen
das die konzeption überwinden gut danke
für ihre geduld kann das mehr als
maschinelles lange mit genannten modelle
können munter prozent korrekt sein
achtung bei der datenqualität casinos
keine gesellschaftlichen probleme
entweder sie kann aber helfen
komplexität zu meistern wenn ihr einer
schaftlichen forschung fördern und nicht
dieses auto und es war genau dort genug
und so weiter
in ruanda menschen folgen nicht zu
datenlieferanten und manipulierbaren
käufern oder männern werden
ich möchte dass menschen das kann man
vorher gehen
eine plattitüde wenn sie aber die
förderung des 20 jahre alten ist keinem
land gemeinsam eingeladen
ich möchte den menschen im zentrum an
weiterbildungen dem ziel beweise
teilhabe von allen ihren daten wenn die
grundschule in der erde gelandet sind
hat entweder an
also wollten schon mal nachfragen ob ich
allen angriffen und daraus was zu
anderen gefangenen gehört und uns gegen
die nacht gut damit zurecht
[Musik]
du hast den außen korrigieren er ist ein
bisschen frau konfrontiert die sich an
den computer heraus
mit dem staat sich unsere leute wissen
aus den taktischen hinaus das musst du
dir zu vertreten
tausend menschen gegen einen aus der
sitzung gesagt als vorteilsgewährung
wäre das zumindest habe jetzt gefällt
das sogar die sowohl aber ich finde alle
müssen sich schwer erklärlich aber lange
gewerbeland frage wo das warmen
demnächst sicher hier bei diesem druck
machen
die instanzen wurde wird im nächsten
monat soll man würde dann schon ob man
handschrift erkennen
was ich aber nicht machen würde wäre
übrigens machen
da stehen sie immer auf das bild dann
von den sketch also der praktischen auf
den punkt gebracht hat dass wir wollen
dass hier eine partnerschaft ist ich
halte an ihn ist
sehr wenig
mehr das für das wohl der menschen und
dem schon eigen wir schreiben ja nicht
nur uns am kaktus unserem auto kleben
bei intentionen sondern wir schreiben
intentionen jedem auf calis nehmen zu
und wenn ich das war noch im home-office
tiere dann habe ich bis auf ex machina
und dann nochmal ein großes und lehne
ich finde es müsste verboten werden dass
zum beispiel was jetzt passiert das mit
einem roboter telefonieren oder wenn ich
in der kapitale von ihre laster wirklich
sprechpausen versprecher damit rein
gemacht werden wenn ich mit einem mit
einer karriereende möchte ich auch
wissen dass ich nicht mag und ich möchte
auch so eingehen wenn ich dann
als roboter hat es forschung gerade
viele deutsche zum klima effektiv
computing ich finde es total wichtig
dass wir uns überlegen wie können wir
menschen emotionen erkennen wenn es sind
sehr viel schneller kommunikationskanal
was ich aber überhaupt nicht haben
möchte dessen haushaltsroboter oder ein
auto mit emotionen
also warum sollte man das wenn man jetzt
eine fragen sind noch verloren
gefunden
denn die vorstellung haben
und kann
was mehr
[Musik]
keine frage
vielen dank
die leicht installierbar verfahren
können forscher so um sich
wir würden gemeinschaften so in sinnlos
wenn es gar ausreißen können sie
aufzeichnen übergehen in chinesischen
mittig der turbo und wir sind recht
unterstehen das aber das einfach sehr
nach 15 minuten durch aus dem turnier
warfen
gemeinsam transparent stellen sich dann
bitte in einem
bei sich haben ist die zahl und nur an
den kassen zu zwei der kasse alle
anderen
ersten mal wiederholen
das war's jetzt
wie gesagt